[Music]
foreign
to the Transformers lore the robots are
sentient beings from the planet called
Cybertron they are a rays of
shape-shifting cybernetic organisms who
can transform into various modes such as
Vehicles animals and even everyday
objects Transformers are living beings
despite their mechanical bodies and they
have their own unique way of creating
new members of their species unlike
organic life forms most cybertronians
reproduce asexually but the process is
complex and varies across different
continuities the creation of a new
Transformer plays a significant role in
their species origin and culture with
individual methods of reproduction
differing widely and no I'm not gonna
comment on sexual reproduction of
Transformers it's too ridiculous only
organic beings like humans have dual
Sexes to procreate so let's get to it
the first one mechanical Construction in
the early days of the Transformers
franchise they were built like machines
with their white parts and Technical
knowledge once constructed these
Transformers would come to life as fully
sentient individuals examples of this
include the creation of the dynabots and
the trypticons in the original cartoon
however as the franchise evolved the
mystical aspects of cybertronian biology
took precedence and building
Transformers like machines were
abandoned nevertheless variations and
new interpretations of this concept have
emerged over time for instance the
cartoon-based wing Universe introduced
the Cyber factories which Mars produce
Transformers on Earth in the 2005 IDW
continuity the concept of coal
construction combined mechanically
assembled bodies with spark infusion in
certain stories mechanically built units
are portrayed as mindless drones without
an animating spot operating on
pre-programmed directives
secondly forging and protoforms in the
G1 cartoon they were manufactured of
forged by the quintessence here the
Transformers start their lives as
protoforms which are partially formed
circuits that can be modified as needed
these protoforms are stored in stasis
spots filled with nutrient gels until
they receive a spark typically from The
Matrix in the absence of a matrix an
alternative method involves attuning the
protoform to a similar energy a
wavelength and then providing a
concentrated burst of Energon to Grand
life however this method is rarely used
due to its high resource consumption
once a spot is infused into a protoform
it undergoes a reformatting process
where it designs its own robot and
Alternate modes while some speculate
that there could be other ways of
creating Transformers and here are three
others number three is spark infusion as
the Transformers franchise progress it
became clear that Transformers were Not
Mere automatons but 40 sentient beings
the creation of transform involved
infusing their physical form with a life
force referred to as a spark the Marvel
Comics introduced The Creation Matrix a
precursor to The Matrix of leadership as
the artifact that brought Transformers
to life the cartoon introduced Vector
Sigma a powerful supercomputer that
granted sentience to Megatron's
non-centered robots turning them into
stunticons the 2007 movie introduced the
allspark a similar life-giving artifact
derived from the afterlife Concept in
base machines the allspark was a cube
that is an ancient and infinitely
Limitless powerful cybertronian artifact
which had the power to bring lifeless
technology upon contact including cars
and even cookware
this idea carried over to the
Transformers animated cartoon where the
old spark could bring machines to life
ranging from articulate fully sentient
Transformers into animalistic All-Star
mutations The Peculiar Energon also have
transformative effects for example in
the botbots storyline Energon radiation
infused everyday objects in human
shopping malls giving them cybertronian
robot forms similarly angle mods energy
had the same power to evolve normal
organic animals into maximals and
Predacons overall the Transformers
franchise has introduced various
Concepts and artifacts that Grant life
and sentience to Transformers ranging
from the creation Matrix the vector
Sigma the all-spark and Energon these
are what gives the Transformers what is
the equivalent of a soul
number four budding according to the
Transformers generation 2 Comics early
Transformers reproduced through a
process called budding after their
creation by Primus Transformers had the
ability to generate an energized liquid
metal Mass from within their bodies this
Mass would then separate from the parent
Transformer becoming a new cybertronian
this process was depicted as a communal
event with other Transformers
surrounding the building robot in a
circle once a desired population level
was reached Primus halted the practice
and erased on memory of it however when
the cybertronians rediscovered and
revived the budding process after The
Disappearance of the Ark primus's life
force became spread thin among them as
successive generations of budget
Transformers emerged they became less
sentient and emotional Additionally the
byproduct of this process was the
creation of the Swarm a separate life
form the Transformers who underwent the
budding process retain a primal link to
their offsprings for example when
onslaught's descendant mindset was
destroyed also experienced some intense
pain similarly the liege maximum claimed
that he would sense the death of his
descendant Megatron
and number five cloning Transformers
have a form of genetic material that can
be copied and manipulated by scientists
to create clones depending on the
storylines these clone Transformers can
either be identical replicas of the
original or have distinct names and
different color schemes personalities
and Alternate modes in the latter case
they are essentially new individuals
with limited connection to the original
Transformer beyond the fact that they
were created through cloning the
creation of Transformer clones can take
various forms blurring the boundary
between biological procreation and
mechanical replication in many cases it
involves utilizing protoforms partially
from circuits and CNA cybertronian
genetic material and some clothes are
created through the surgical procedures
perform on existing Transformers
contrary to expectations clones are not
always physically identical to their
progenitors depending on the specific
Universe clones May exhibit different
color schemes vastly different alternate
modes and especially personalities
so those are the five ways Transformers
are created and reproduced anyway I hope
you have enjoyed watching this video do
hit the like button for support
subscribe and take care of that belt
button for regular updates on new videos
take care fam